let's go
yes yes yes
uh what a sexy audience
yeah all right happy Wednesday everyone
so great news out of NYC this week I
made it another week without being
murdered
but also for NYPD Transit cops caught an
alleged killer and a suspected serial
Slasher in under just 24 hours
yeah yeah
it's about time huh
yeah it wasn't that hard since they were
both wearing I heart murder and slashing
t-shirts
but seriously you won't believe how the
police did this they used this amazing
technology
pictures
yep the cops recognize both the perps
from internal Department wanted posters
it's amazing how this old thing works
see you have a guy's description and
then you circulate it
and that helps you catch the guy it's
insane pretty awesome
except well we really don't do that
anymore that's why I bring it up mug
shots as you know are now considered
racist just like everything else is
racist
now you got to remember after the George
Floyd riots one of the first things to
go when we decided policing was evil was
the use of mug shots San Francisco
police chief William Scott announced it
early on they would no longer release
mug shots of those arrested unless they
posed imminent danger to the public now
I know I know isn't that why they're
under arrest in the first place
no they're under arrest because we're
all bigots you racist homophobic
transphobic meat-eating monster
but yes apparently there's compelling
research suggesting a correlation
between mug shots and a perception of
bias translation if a picture was once
worth a thousand words now it's just
four nothing to see here
now they're not the only city with such
a policy it's everywhere it's like all
liberal City governments spin a wheel
and every answer is the same racism
but wouldn't releasing the mug shots
lead to transparency to see if these
arrests are actually Justified
yeah yeah only a racist would say that
your white Hood's probably at the dry
cleaners
look there's no need to recount San
Francisco's Horrors now when they talk
about the big one it's never about an
earthquake it's after a sidewalk pooper
eats tacos
the list of companies fleeing that town
is longer than the list of cats exes
and according to the Wall Street Journal
hotels in San Fran are selling so cheap
crack houses are complaining about the
declining property values
they turn to city with beautiful weather
and an economy worth billions into a
third world hell hole where the only
hope is an earthquake it's Mogadishu but
with seafood
the city's become a metaphor the perfect
encapsulation of progressive policies
taken to their logical end where
criminals do as they please and
residents are told you know that's life
in the big city
I was thinking I should move back to the
Bay Area and become a warlord but I
still can't afford a one bedroom
fact is ignoring mug shots as your city
hits Rock Bottom is like pretending your
gang green will go away if you just
don't look at it at first they told you
not to believe Your Lying Eyes now they
want you blind instead of facing the
truth that is obvious to anyone with
eyes that those in charge continue the
fantasy that is democratic Urban policy
and I can sum up that policy quite
easily there's no such thing as evil
other than you so in real evil does
strike we won't bother warning you
because you're the problem not them and
you won't see it coming so you can't
stop it
look at Chicago last weekend after 75
people were shot and 23 killed including
two kids a police chief there responded
it's unfortunate yeah strong words
that's what I say when I forget my
assistant's birthday and we share the
same birthday
I get two presents
but two real life dozen murders in two
days bummer man Chicago mayor Brandon
Johnson blames crime on disinvestment
and I agree it's funny how investors
don't want to keep building stores that
get set on fire
but this is the pattern in our Damron
cities the Mayors and legislators invent
new ways to handcuff the cops then hire
police Chiefs who will go along with
this Kabuki theater and kids die mostly
once of color because they just can't
buy a mansion in a city that has Law
Enforcement just like a black lives
matter founder did
so let me suggest something to the top
cops out there ignore the Mayors and do
your job and to people living in these
cities thank them when they get the job
done it's what I do every time they
escort me
just end there
I thank them all the time especially
after I wake up nude in the Central Park
fountain
now maybe maybe one day even liberals
will realize that the rose-colored
glasses are actually covered in blood
let's a welcome
tonight's guest his life coach quit
after one session actor writer and
comedian Jamie LaSalle
her pronouns are top and secrets former
deputy National Security adviser Katie
McFarland
foreign
starts every joke the same way by
apologizing for the last one comedian
Joe Mackey
[Applause]
and she's like a pair of scissors small
sharp and it's best to never run with
her Fox News contributor cats him
[Applause]
uh Jamie you told me that you feel bad
for the criminals when their mug shots
are released I do feel bad because I
know what this is like really yeah for a
couple years in almost every comedy club
in America I was on a most not wanted
poster oh
and uh so it's so much crazy stuff going
there's nobody that's happy about all
the terrible terrible things going on in
this in the subway system except for
Uber and Lyft yeah they're making quite
a killing I literally feel like they
could say like sponsored by Uber and
Lyft right like who would have thought
the New York City subway would be more
dangerous than Jared from Subway
did you see the did you see the one guy
was I and I them getting rid of the mug
shots Yeah it's you're right like this
was the original facial recognition
software exactly right and I think
they're also forgetting one key
component which is that they're like fun
to look at they really are you know but
the one guy who stabbed people yeah he
um if you saw he's a repeat offender he
robbed a bank like he robbed a bank with
a note like just like two months ago and
I just got thinking like how
embarrassing would it be to be like the
teller that got robbed like with a note
do you know like if you're like in the
break room and the one guy's like oh
remember I got robbed with that gun you
know and then oh remember you got you
remember you got robbed at note point
it is true yeah the note thing is crazy
yeah you can't call him on a note right
and you gotta think like that's the only
note a teller is getting yeah if someone
has a note that's the only note you're
gonna I like to have a little fun like
when I go to the bank and I'll just act
like super suspicious yeah and then I'll
hand him a little note and on the on the
back it'll say give me all my money
all right with my account number that
was uh for four decent jokes yeah yeah
better than your usual uh batting
average
uh Katie do you have a mug shot do you
lead a wild and crazy life is there a
mug shot of you what do you think
this but it's probably been buried it's
classified yes it is but look mug shots
so this morning at a very early morning
I I click on my Wall Street Journal
subscription and what mugshot do I see
Greg Gutfeld oh yes in fact fabulous mug
shots of you the Wall Street Journal
which usually Praises you know Nobel
laureates or billionaires has this huge
puff piece about Greg Gutfeld king of
late night television Superstar at Fox
News the guy who can do any Howard I
mean it was well it blew me away wow
[Applause]
yeah you're right
yeah I saw that I saw the article came
out it was it's an interesting process
when people write about you because you
know more about the story than anybody
else does because you're you and you
watch the things they remove and you
watch the things they put in like if
they want to look like they're balanced
and you have a fact they will counter
that fact with a non-fact
[Laughter]
that's what they did but the pictures
were the pictures the mug shots were
terrific so was this a way so that you
didn't have to answer the question no I
mean if you'd like me to answer the
question here's the problem with San
Francisco is that they don't have
mugshots so then if you're a cop and
you're trying to look for the bad guy
that's slashers the murderers you have
no idea who you're looking for so then
your choice is well maybe I'm going to
look at everybody well that's completely
impossible so what's your other choice
I'm not gonna look for anybody therefore
you have San Francisco is murder capital
yeah exactly you know what you just I
see that in New York I'll be going up
the street and cops just walk by people
because this is not even the person
could be doing anything it's just like
why arrest them there's nothing I can do
Joe you must love this uh you can do
whatever you want man Greg I don't
commit any crimes but uh someone who
looks just like me named Tony Camaro is
quite the swashbuckler around town
I'll tell you what though Greg whenever
the government wants to keep something
secret it's for their benefit not for
yours it's the same reason I wear a
shirt in the swimming pool yes
got a bit of a stomach hair issue
at what age did you decide to wear a
shirt in the pool 12 12. yeah
yeah and you never stopped well I'll
tell you what Greg there wouldn't be any
mugshot of me at the pool because no
one's taking that photo
actually changed the mug shot Joe and
made it more positive called it like the
perpy portrait and you know and you
could like wear a nice hat you could
make it like one of those old old
western type portraits oh yeah where you
can like select the background or you
can like have a medieval one yes or
you're you have like chain link and all
that yeah that's a good idea thank you
all right cat
what do you make of this are you do you
think that mug shots are racist or
discriminatory no no you don't I don't
that's good all right uh I think it's
also interesting that both of these guys
basically got caught because they were
trying to use public transportation
without paying for it at all
which I think now criminals are going to
start maybe wanting to pay for the
public transportation because I mean
like if you've done some really bad
crimes like killing or slashing then you
might want to be like you know what
maybe I'll pay this small amount of
money to avoid getting caught but one of
the guys he got kicked off the bus and
the cop said that they found him on the
corner on the street eating a bag of
chips he bought how do you make that
calculation yeah not get paid for the
bus but the chips crucial how do you
know it came for him it's they said bot
I don't know here's the thing though you
just proved the point that uh the broken
windows yeah three works because you
arrest the guy who jumps the turnstile
you find out that's actually not true
there's a lot of studies that prove that
it does yes but you just disproved it no
I didn't anecdotes how does it feel how
does it feel it feels like you don't
understand the difference between an
anecdote and empirical evidence
empirical evidence is made up of a
collection of anecdotes that's called
statistics little lady
thank you in your face am I being
dismissive or missing my point no no no
no no you just brought up we probably
work through this that the guy was
busted jumping to Turn Style and it
turns out there have been comprehensive
studies done on the NYPD that say that
it doesn't make a difference in terms of
violent crime so and I also think that
civil liberties are crucial and we can't
be giving up our own Freedom typical
communist
Communists don't believe in civil
liberties
like I said
am I the only one that actually has
their I actually do have a mug shot
really for what yeah this is where I got
in trouble for I was peeing in a pool
um
I was 16. I was on the diving it was a
typing pool
oh you're gonna die I ruined your joke
that's okay I ruined your joke
oh
you can't back it up I don't care though
you're so great my show I'll ruin your
joke
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else